The Joe Rogan experience,
you are sometimes say artificial life instead of artificial intelligence.
Yeah,
because I think that it's a life form.
It's a stupid way to look at it.
As curious to think about like how do you think about artificial and like what
do you picture?
I picture human beings being like electronic caterpillars that are building a
cocoon that they have no real knowledge of our understanding and through this
and new life forms can emerge a life form that doesn't need cells and meeting
with x and y chromosomes doesn't need any of that shit exists purely in software
and in hardware and in ones and Zeros and that this is a new form of life.
This is when the inevitable rise of essentially being the inevitable.
I mean,
I think if we don't get hit when the asteroid within a thousand years or
whatever the number,
the time frame is,
someone is going to figure out how to make a thing,
who had just walks around and does whatever it wants and lives like a person
that's not outside the realm of possibility.
And I think that if that does happen,
that's artificial life and this is the new life and it's probably going to be
better than what we are.
I mean we are as basically,
if you go back and look about,
you know,
three hundred thousand four hundred thousand years ago when we were some
Australia [inaudible] type creature,
how many of them would ever look at the future and go,
I hope I never get a Tesla.
The last thing I want is a fucking phone.
Last thing I want,
it's air conditioning and television.
The last thing I want is to be able to talk in a language that other people can
understand and to be able to call people on the phone.
Fuck all that man.
I like living out here running from Jaguars and shit and constantly getting
jacked by bears,
you know?
No,
they wouldn't think that way.
And I think if something comes out of us and makes us obsolete,
but it's,
it's missing all the things that suck about people.
I mean,
it won't be good.
It won't be good on our are hard things suck of a people can wait.
War,
violence,
thievery,
people stealing things from people,
people robbing people thing that those dark parts of human nature.
I think,
uh,
the suffering and justice,
I think all of that is necessary for us to discover the better angels.
I don't think you can,
as surgery we can talk,
let's talk about saint she Hanson and creating artificial life,
but I think even those life forms,
even those systems need to have the darker parts.
But why is that?
Is that because of our own biological limitations in the fact that we exist in
this world of animals where animals are eating other animals and running,
there's always do you always have to prepare for evil?
You have to prepare for intruders.
You have to prepare for,
you know,
predators and this is essentially like this mechanism is there to ensure that
things don't get sloppy.
Things continued to about,
look,
if the Jaguars keeping and the people and the people don't figure out how to
make a fucking house,
they get eaten and that's it.
Or you figure out the house and then you make weapons,
you find off the fucking Jaguar.
Okay,
great,
you made it.
You're in a city now.
See you had to have that Jaguar there in order to inspire you to make enough
safety so that your kids can grow old enough.
They can get information from all the people that did survive as well,
and they can accumulate all that information and create air conditioning and
automobiles and guns and keep those fucking jaguars from eating your kids.
Right?
This is,
this is what had to take place as a biological entity,
but once you surpass that and once you become this thing that doesn't need
emotion,
doesn't need it,
doesn't need conflict,
it doesn't need to be inspired.
It never gets lazy.
It doesn't have these things that we have built into us as a biological system.
Like if you looked at us as wet,
where operating software,
it's not good software,
right?
It's software design for cave people and we're,
you know,
we're just trying to force it in the cars and force it into cubicles.
But part of the problem with people in their unhappiness is that all of these
human reward systems that have been set up through evolution and natural
selection to,
to have these instincts to stay alive,
they're no longer relevant in today's society.
So they become,
they become road rage.
They become,
you know,
extracurricular violence.
They became,
they become depression.
They become all these different things that people suffer from.
So that's one perspective.
Yes.
That basically our software through this evolutionary process was necessary to
arrive where we are.
But it's outdated at this point.
Well,
it's necessary for us to succeed,
succeed in a purely,
almost a Darwinist way in a sense that survived through Ellucian,
especially since we're so weak.
I mean,
it's really,
we became this week because we got so good at protecting ourselves from all the
bad things.
Yeah.
Okay.
The other perspective is that we're actually incredibly strong and this is the
best that the universe can create actually were at the height.
This is where at the height of creation,
there's,
there's a beauty in this tension,
in this dance between good and evil,
between,
uh,
like happiness and depression,
life and death,
and that through that struggle,
that's not just a useful tool to get us from Jaguars to cities,
but that is the beautiful thing that,
that,
that is like what the universe was built for her.
That that is the height.
Like our current,
the,
the evolution and the creation that results from it is the height of creation.